Hey youtubers, it's Charlie! Thanks everyone
that submitted questions on my Episode 1 video
earlier this week. A lot of you weren't huge
fans of the black and white, just remember
they do try to get really creative with the
intros every once in a while as much it is
going on right now it is of is is really going
to go down as the legend of the protein bar
that was like the biggest thing I heard people
talking about right after the episode so just
careful response is beginning to question
starting with number one say asks what's with
the crazy booby-trapped town Morgan making
a brief appearance did you take my protein
bar will about Morgan is it a brief appearance
he's going to be a series regular for at least
the first part of the season I don't know
if he's going to be here for the second half
and I certainly hope so he's really interesting
Lennie James status is to be determined I
believe he's a series regular currently though
but he's talking about something from season
three is season three episode 12 where he
Michonne and Carl go back to his place you
see Michonne eating in the background I know
she's at least eating chips she may have also
eaten the protein bar writing that's the consensus
that she definitely ain't the protein bar
she does get called on eating stuff in the
episode her responses the mat said welcome
so like who cares the showrunner Scott Gimple
after the episode said that he was actually
really blown away at how people were upset
over her maybe taking the protein bar his
response was just like hey you know there's
a lot of terrible stuff happening let her
have it letter have the protein bar in the
context of the episode that was really just
him saying hello to Michelle, feeling her
out again so it's really not a conversation
about a protein bar at all issues him reaching
for a shared experience that they have something
that they have in common next question all
the asks do you think that a fear The Walking
Dead did not have The Walking Dead in the
title it would be as popular no I mean it
definitely wouldn't be as popular but you
could say that of Star Wars or anything else
that is part of a franchise the committee
a Star Wars spinoff movie with characters
you never seen before in a different part
of the Galaxy would you know it was a Star
Wars movie if they didn't tell you this from
a marketing perspective. If you to do a spinoff
of any big franchise it would be the worst
decision in the world cannot use the title
of the really famous thing that you're spinning
off the different things that they've done
with fear The Walking Dead is that it's not
like them taking characters they've already
established in creating another series based
on them is it's like characters that we've
never met before that's the weird part next
question gamer and surgeons asks it might
just be me seeing it but do you reckon that
they are intentionally portraying Rick as
an antagonist or am I crazy or maybe both
know they're definitely trying to make you
think that Rick is the antagonist that has
just been messing with us of course Rick is
the protagonist think they just want you to
feel like there's going to be conflict in
the group you can get too mad at the writers
for stirring the pot that way just because
this is a drama it's as much a gritty drama
as it is a genre show you know like comic
book zombie for Rick is just like the next
logical step for his character last season
though I think is when he hit the boiling
point when Michelle just cold clocked them
and knocked them right out next question Gabriel
asks do you think that Rick and Morgan will
remain friends if not who do you think would
be the one to end the friendship when I don't
think that they're going like ever completely
break up I think that Morgan eventually will
pass on if he doesn't end up dying but he
is so firmly entrenched in his new philosophy
like this crazy weird Jedi wanderer philosophy
that he has that I do think he will be one
of the few people who won't completely drink
Rick's Kool-Aid soda certain point left either
drink that Kuwait completely like completely
become a survivor oral have to go somewhere
else but even if that ends up happening I
I don't think that they would have like a
major falling out with you know they beat
each other's throats like Rick and Shane Morgan
is again a dig Lori's corpse up and try to
take Rick's family from him again next question
soccer star asks this may not be a direct
for this exact episode but Carol seems to
be still acting useless how do you think the
best would act if she was in Alexandria if
Carol died and she survived will you and pretty
much everybody else Beth has her fans but
Carol's the better character I think it best
were still alive with they might have ended
up doing is giving her the Arkansas she has
right now where she goes super hard-core just
starts carrying an automatic weapon around
like it's her boyfriend which I guess means
that it would end up dying sometime during
the episode the joke about Beth's boyfriends
are that they all die really really quickly
if you want to get rid of like any of the
male characters in the show just have them
go out with Beth next question Judge Holden
asks would've been just easier to burn the
horde in the quarry all the work to get the
route set up yet you tell you why go through
all that trouble figure just throw some firebombs
in the quarry will one because I think they
wanted to have that big drawnout drama like
that wouldn't be an episode if they didn't
do that the second reason in the one that
I think is more important is is because even
though it's Rick's idea part of the drama
of the show is characters making really bad
decisions and it completely messing everything
up so the fun for us is just seeing belt the
Walker problem just blow up exploding guts
all over everyone's faces next question Michael
asks who out of the Alexandria folk would
you say is most likely to turn against Rick
or tried to take control of the community
library I don't think that anybody is going
to try and wrestle control from the end is
technically still in charge even though the
deferring a lot to Rick I think of anyone's
going to be causing problems for the community
it's probably going to be Enid or some of
the new characters that we don't know a lot
about yet there is one new character the we
haven't met yet the dog a comic book character
that the show is bringing on call Denise Cloyd
she's gonna be like the new doctor but I I
don't think that she's going to be a good
character that is going to cause a bunch of
problems for everyone she's relatively benign
next question Gabriel asks do you think that
Carl will ooze in either the season was bent
there's been a lot of weird pictures from
the set I try to avoid spoilers for The Walking
Dead because there are so many there so many
spoilers but I'd generally don't expect any
characters to get maimed long-term just because
it would be really weird for actors to have
to live with that for the next like three
seasons like the governor lost and I Merle
lost a hand there there probably a little
bit better it acting through stuff like that
Chandler Riggs great kid but we really don't
even know what his arc is the season and is
not the strongest actor on the show in and
generally things like back in feel kind of
gimmicky like ours going to hurt this character
to make them interesting I can't really say
no they're not gonna maim him I mean I don't
know if they're going to do that it really
just depends on where his arc is going this
season if you're one of those people this
hoping for like stuff like this to happen
they are doing a lot more comic book storyline
so I'd I think the chances of increased dramatically
next question the keel asks why did Glenn
have to empty at the shop if they did need
to do anything and decided it was pointless
wasn't it when I was in a pointless state
they wanted him and Nick to have that moment
I think that's the only reason that that whole
thing existed just so they can have that save
it was really almost more of an arc for Nick
like they wanted him to turn into a good character
in order to do that he had to have that saves
they can had to be in this this dangerous
situation on their own so I think that's why
they had to clear that shop next question
notebook asks did anybody else not see Aaron
or Carl this episode I couldn't spot them
or Rosita will Rosita was in the infirmary
and I we saw Aaron in the flashbacks Carl
to I think but in present-day they were just
off doing other things but thank you so much
everyone for 70 questions is always a ton
of fun to do congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner to Danielle Mark you and a
$20 Amazon gift card just private message
me on the back and my channels and your contact
info so there's gonna be a new round of the
giveaway whenever I post my episode to video
it was such a big cliffhanger last week you
can almost view it as a two-parter these first
two episodes were rolling into the weekend
Maisie Williams from game of thrones is going
to be on Doctor Who tomorrow so even if you
haven't watched Doctor Who before I would
advise you to watch this episode is going
to be a lot of fun Maisie Williams is totally
bad ass I also still need to do of flash arrow
Q&A in this is a much new footage so my dinner
trailer video for that to that that would
be Saturday night serving get pumped into
don't worry there will be new game of thrones
this weekend to lots of awesome stuff happening
so acacias haven't seen it you can click here
for all my walking dead season six videos
and click here to learn about Hulk being in
Thor Ragnarok. thank you so much watching
everybody high five and I'll see you tonight!